[Music]
all right lots of news in the sports
world today the oaklands could be
on the move or major league baseball
could be forcing the ace
and the local government there to fish
or cut bait ron futrell joins us live
from
las vegas ballpark with some
possibilities for the athletics hey ron
yeah chris how does the las vegas
athletic sound okay could
could be a long shot here but major
league baseball today
gave permission to the athletics to look
for a new facility a new city
for them to play in now for years
they've been going back and forth
with the city of oakland and trying to
upgrade their facilities something
different than oakland alameda's
coliseum
these are the plans that they've worked
out so far but that's all they are just
plans good looking drawings it would be
a billion dollars for the stadium 12
billion dollars overall
for the entire project but good looking
drawings is all they are
at this point no money to do this and no
private funding
sounds a little bit like the story of
the oakland raiders that they went
through
a few years ago before they packed up
and moved to vegas
that's all you have to do is look at the
dysfunction
up there and you'll understand it again
it comes down to
we really did try to stay in the bay
area the a's made it tough for us to
stay in the bay area
the city made it tough for us to stay in
berry and i'm talking about the
political apparatus but the a's are now
finding out what it's like to be on the
other end of that
well the a's have played the games in
las vegas before a couple of years ago
at the las vegas ballpark they played an
exhibition game
here at that time then in 1996 this was
sort of interesting
they played six regular season games at
cashman field
while they were waiting for oakland's
alameda coliseum to be renovated
billy being the owner of the oakland a's
has been here a few times and he just
loves this ballpark by the way
if you take a look of course the aaa
aviators getting warming up for the game
behind us tonight are the the affiliate
for the oakland a's have a great
relationship with the oakland a's
they like that relationship they've got
their there are no plans to build
a major league ballpark here in las
vegas now attendance in oakland is
rather interesting
right now they've got 12 000 fans that
are allowed under covert rules
to go to the ballpark they're only
getting half that which is lowest they
have the lowest attendance right now
in the major leagues do the oakland
athletics
worse than major league baseball at
downtown summerlin ron fuchar reporting
eight sports now all